a key debate on terrorism had em ep's
warning against repeating the mistakes
of 911 could new legislation such as
passenger name record really be the
difference to help secure Europe's
borders it's time to find out welcome to
the agenda the director of Europol
warned last week of further attacks
being conducted on EU soil congrates
powers for them help combat the growing
threats in the days of the attacks EU
justice and Home Affairs ministers
agreed to upgrade your post
counterterrorism capabilities a new
counterterrorism center will also be
launched in the new year to help member
states better coordinate and share
information a vote in the civil
liberties committee to confirm your
polls new powers takes place on Monday
before the year's clothes MEP s want to
push to finalize the once controversial
eu-wide passenger name record that
privacy issues still need to be sorted
out negotiations are currently ongoing
with member states that passenger name
record is being held up by the
finalization of data protection reform
once that's done privacy afforded under
P&R can be sorted follow the debate on
Monday has public empathy for the plight
of refugees weekend at the Strasbourg
camry m ep's underlined the need to
stand united with refugees who are
themselves victims of terrorism a second
busy day for Parliament civil liberties
committee who will discuss migration
legislation proposals especially the
relocation mechanism and designated safe
third countries for Refugees and now
time to see what's coming up at the mini
plenary in Brussels on Wednesday turning
waste into a resource could recycling or
refurbishing goods and materials be the
key to increasing jobs and growth find
out more when Emily's discuss the
Commission's presentation of the
circular economy package and also look
out for debate on the current situation
in Hungary is it upholding EU values of
democracy rule of law and human rights
and that's all we have this agenda take
care and enjoy doing